mr carl benjamin
also known as sargon of akkad also known
as
patreon's uh number one enemy at the
moment how are you today sir
i'm good i didn't really consider myself
patreon's number one enemy i don't know
why
they're doing this but um apparently
subscribe star has started working for
people now so it's kind of
uh an issue that's passed us all by i
suppose
yeah it's it's kind of in and out in and
out pretty fast right
yeah it's been strange for the uh for
the listeners who don't know
what's occurred over the last few months
could you give us the the rundown the
zeitgeist
yeah um basically patreon
found me insulting a bunch of nazis
on a live stream on quite an obscure
channel and
they took umbrage to the way that i was
insulting them and they decided to
delete my patreon account without
warning which is strange because i mean
the terms of service obviously don't say
that they
track down things that you do elsewhere
on the internet and use that to judge
you but
apparently they do so be warned if you
have a patreon account
so patreon was your way of assisting
your channel
sargon of a card on youtube crowdfunding
it allows fans to get
like exclusive content and and early
access to
to certain things and stuff like that
and by being shut down from that i'm
going to guess that that was a
a primary source of income that you were
driving your from your channel right
it was certainly one of the major ways i
was monetizing my channel yeah
um the youtube has a join
feature that you can turn on but i'm
really hesitant to do it because it's
something like 30
of the money that people donate through
it are taken by youtube themselves
whereas with with patreon there's only
five percent
yeah and with subscribe star it's only
five percent as well
okay uh just 30 huge amount in my
opinion
it is a big amount yeah well it's
obviously youtubers starting to see a
a gap in the fact that if you've got
companies that have agendas and who are
potentially gonna disenfranchise
the uh the content creators so
well that was that was the point of
patreon in the first place
that youtube youtube are the ones saying
we have advertisers therefore
you can't say certain things or be you
know quite edgy
and push boundaries you know there are a
lot of advertisers who you know
corporate
you know sponsors for you know and
advertisers who don't want you to be too
edgy not they really care i think in my
opinion but
they would in demonetizing certain
videos and things like that and patreon
offered itself as hey look
you can keep your content going without
advertisers without having to get these
corporations involved
we'll facilitate you doing that and now
they're like oh actually but if you say
something we don't like
and you don't apologize then you know we
i mean nobody gave him the opportunity
to apologize but
you know but the if you say something we
don't like we're going to kick you off
it's just like
so what happens what happens when you
wake up on
the morning of whatever day it is and
you find out your patreon account's gone
it's it's not a very nice feeling i'm
gonna be honest you know
because i mean i was i was relying on
that money quite significantly
um i mean
it is it is kind of terrifying knowing
that you're living under a sword of
damocles
you know like i every day i wake up and
i check that my youtube channel is still
there
i'm not joking it sounds terrible
doesn't it
you know it's like every morning you
phone up your boss just to check you
have a job to go into yeah you know it's
like
that's how i feel about it sometimes and
it's it's it's my choice obviously i'm
the one who started doing a youtube
channel but
you know it wasn't like this when i
started you know
it wasn't i mean like monkey jones was a
young comedian who
mocks uh he mocked elliot elliot roger
and he actually
ended up doing some real really good
work with it because he went through and
read his crazy manifesto and things like
this and he would explain why elliot
roger was such a
you know a lunatic and he got his entire
youtube presence deleted um for being
apparently controversial and it's like
well
you know come on the controversial stuff
is the stuff that's interesting isn't it
you know no one's just
watching daytime television on youtube
are they they're going to go somewhere
else where the controversial content
goes
because that'll make that new platform
cough cough [ __ ] you cough
uh a better alternative i think but i
think bitschu's got a better model
because it it it's stored like torrents
so it's across
thousands of different computers um
decentralizing it and i think
so they don't have like uh you know they
don't have a giant warehouse full of
hard drives
um to keep everything on so it's i think
that's the future it's just youtube's
currently the dominant market share
many anyway sorry yeah no totally so
you've woken up and you found out that
how many how many um subscribers or uh
patrons did you have at the time
about three and a half thousand that is
a very significant number isn't it
yeah it's quite a lot you know and so
and i mean and honestly it's just
i mean i just laugh because to be honest
with you i've kind of been expecting
something
for a while um i feel the impending
fisting but you just didn't know whether
it was from
youtube or twitter or instagram or
yeah basically i think a bunch of a
bunch of prominent
uh free freedom activist youtubers
have been in the crosshairs for quite
some time now
um and i mean obviously really it
started with the alt-right
um and i objected to it then and then it
came on alex jones and it was
it's been a it's been a very slippery
slope since then
and the and it really is the tightening
of the sort of noose of censorship
because i mean you know like you know
you say okay we're not gonna
platform nazis okay well you know i
that i can't it's hard to argue that you
know i mean i can sit there and make the
same argument from their freedom but
if every you know if there's this giant
consensus to do it
you you're yelling into a gale you know
and then it comes to someone like alex
jones and alex jones no matter what you
think of him he wasn't a nazi
you know he was a radical libertarian
conspiracy theorist
yeah and he he was the one going oh
they're gonna they're gonna shut us down
and all the sort of stuff and then on
one day they shut him down completely
and it was like okay well that's
and that that was enough to get a lot of
people paying attention yeah
and then on patreon they got rid of me
james alsop and milo yiannopoulos
um james alsop's a white identitarian
but he's not a nazi
you know he's not like calling for
violence or anything milo is just
like a conservative and i i'm a
classical liberal so it's
you know the the fact that they've come
they've they've
jumped like several new steps closer and
tighter to the center
and i mean there's there's no particular
reason that milo should have been kicked
off in the first place and i didn't
actually object to it on the day it
happened
but everyone else just ignored it and
then two days later that was it my
patreon was gone as well and that was
like
[ __ ] because milo's had a really bad
run recently being de-platformed like
what's terrifying and you alluded to it
earlier on
is the fact that your connection to your
audience and people who genuinely care
about your content and
essentially your your friends for for
want of a better term if you were to try
and
like create it in the real world
they are at the behest of a man with a
button and the man
the man can press the button and when
the button gets pressed your friendship
with
are you what are you up to now nearly a
million subs on youtube yeah you're
coming up coming on 900 000 something
like that so your friendship with
our connection with a million people is
gone yeah and it's not just
it's not just the the voice that i had
that they're silencing
it's the ability for anyone who wanted
to hear what i had to say
they've been deafened in the process yes
um
and the the whole the whole thing's
really quite terrifying because almost
all of the internet is run from silicon
valley
and so i did a video on starship
troopers a while ago
and i had to read a lot about fascism
because the accusation on the book and
the movie is that it's a fascist book a
movie
it's not um but i did end up having to
read a lot about fascism to be able to
make the distinction because
i mean you know if you don't know much
about either subject it's easy to just
say
guns there for fascism but that's not
how it works um
but one of the things that um fascist
philosopher giovanni gentilly said
about the fascist state that i found
really interesting
is the idea of it being an ethical state
um
as in it has a plan you know
it has a goal and so everything the
state's doing
in a liberal society like we we live in
everything the state should be working
towards is the protection of the rights
and freedoms of the citizen
the state doesn't tell you how to be a
citizen it's there to safeguard
your independence as an individual in
the world
um but the fascist state and the sort of
socialist state is not really like that
they
they have a goal a moral teleology and
they they know
how they you know they've got manifestos
they have a series of steps
on how they can implement these because
i was thinking what on earth would a
liberal manifesto even look like
you know we want everything all the time
from everyone you need a grand plan for
the world to have a manifesto and so
one of the one of the ways that giovanni
gentilly described this i thought was
really fascinating it was like the the
fascist state
is wide awake and has a will of its own
and
you can definitely say that about
silicon valley it's wide awake and has a
will of its own
because you can listen to tim cook
saying that it's a sin
not to censor and then you can listen to
all the other
ceos and i mean jack conte just openly
said we all talk to each other we're
very open and we share
and it's like okay and there's there's a
definitive
kind of culture that's come out of the
sort of bay area in which silicon valley
set
and it's got designs on remodeling the
world
and i don't agree with those designs i
i think they're quite authoritarian and
i i mean it's honestly they're trying to
create the demolition man future
which is a video i'm going to do fairly
soon actually because it's so scary how
unbelievably similar yeah that they want
it but
um yeah sorry this so yeah silicon
valley it scares me
because it kind of acts like a fascist
organization yeah i
i think uh it is it is very worrying
that you have
such a high amount of power concentrated
in such a small place
like it's the equivalent of a market
monopoly oh absolutely
competitive if there was any
competitiveness uh legislation
with regards to having to distribute the
power more evenly geographically because
you're totally right like you you end up
with an echo chamber
like we already everyone that's
listening i'm sure will have heard about
how echo chambers exist online but if
you lump this many
businesses together and this many ceos
in the same
telegram and whatsapp group chats like
what what do you think happens then
yeah and they it's normal for that to
happen you know you form a community
with the people in the local area around
you
you know and people of similar status to
you it's natural that that happens
it's not like it's an evil conspiracy
but
i mean when tim cook was standing at the
recent apple
thing where the the viral clip from
going around
he looked like a preacher he he was very
much saying
he he was he was saying that they had to
i i can't remember word for word
obviously
but um the the general thrust of it is
that it was
on the responsibilities of the big tech
corporations
to project their values out into the
world and to make sure that
the world is run according to these
values and the internet in particular
because
these are the masters of the internet
that we're talking about i mean
tim cook's one of the most powerful men
in the world and
he's saying we have a particular and it
sounded genuinely religious
you know i mean he used religious
terminology he said it's a sin
not to censor and it's like well jesus
christ man you know if we're gonna get
into the realm of what's sinful and not
then
i guess you're gonna have to debate with
the pope or something aren't you because
it sounds so
far away from the vision that most
people think of when they think about
silicon valley's start
up [ __ ] the system guys with long hair
and dreads just doing what they want and
it's free love man and
you know like is this the is this the
vision for silicon valley that was
started like
you know 40 years ago is that really
where it where it was supposed to go
it's it's changed a lot hasn't it
because i mean if you you look at like
paypal was peter thiel
teal however you pronounce it man yeah
yeah exactly elon musk and a bunch of
others
and they're not they're not like far
left lunatics at all
you know i mean they're quite
libertarian in many ways it seems that
the far left have
just moved in slowly but surely and you
know crept
you know it's like a i don't want to say
a plague
[Laughter]
something something you can something
akin to a plague
yeah something yeah yeah i was going to
be more generous
but you know what i mean it's it's over
time the the nature of it has changed i
get that
so you you ended up getting i don't know
whether the term is d platform from
patreon or not but
removed from patreon um and you'd
mentioned about
it happened with milo and it happened
with some other of your contemporaries
but
based on what i saw the immediate
backlash from some other pretty
prominent
figures online gave lent a lot of
publicity and credence to your side of
the story it
certainly seemed with quite a few people
who came out in support of you right
yeah i mean the the the problem is that
patreon didn't even try to really
justify it
um they they can't appeal to their own
terms of service
when doing this that's the thing that's
why people talk about it as if it's a
political maneuver because it does
appear to be a political maneuver
i mean i've been on patreon for four
years and
they knew what i was like when i joined
i haven't really changed you know my
political opinions are
not the same but still in the same vein
you know so
i've not particularly changed that and
i've always been opposed to political
correctness
and they they're effective effectively
saying
because somewhere else you were
politically incorrect on our platform
we're going to get rid of you even
though
our terms and service only said it's
things that happen on our platform
and jack conte literally said you know
we don't care about what you do on
twitter we care about you doing patreon
it's like okay well
that that seems fairly cut and dry to me
and so when they're
just literally reversing this then
i mean how was i to know i possibly
wouldn't have been so
unpolitically correct had i known that
patreon were watching everything
yeah i mean you need to be careful what
you say when you go to the toilet now
or like what you say when you're out
walking the dog
i mean where where does the where does
it finish it is getting quite orwellian
i
i really do think and no it's it's
i mean like i never really thought we'd
end up living in some kind of like
omnipotent panopticon where you you can
no no because like anything you've said
at any point in time or space
can now be found by internet sleuths
if it's on the internet if it's in
social media if it's you know correct
i mean like look at chang yuga's old um
like when he was in college or whatever
his old
blog from the 90s that he had up i mean
it was really rude you know it was it
was like young men's
rude talk you know and you know and i
obviously he's not saying this to
women's faces so it's not like he's
going out and
and saying hey lady you've got a nice
rack you know blah blah blah blah
he did kind of sound like elliot roger
while he was doing it yeah
but that was all dug up like 20 years
later after he had disavowed it like 10
years previously yeah and said look this
is something i did and i'm not proud of
it
but now it doesn't matter and that got
kicked off of the board of the justice
democrats a political organization in
the u.s
and him and kyle kolinsky and so it's
just like it's merciless
yeah absolutely merciless and this is
it's currently happening to tulsi
gabbard right now like
she was raised in a a right-wing
christian anti-gay
household like actively her dad was an
activist against gay rights
um and she grew up naturally with a
bunch of those
opinions yeah as you would expect and
she you know like she was she going to
congress six years ago but before
then she had already changed her mind on
the idea of gay rights which is why she
joined the democrats
and now she's being just grilled for it
like i'm seeing that
she's such a mild person and i'm just
seeing the worst kind of backlash from
the very far left activists
who are now like well if you were once
ever against gay rights then you know
you are forever and we're just going to
treat you like you still hold this
opinion yeah
it's it's such a uh yeah and it's the
the problem is because
everybody wants to have this absolutist
approach to people are either bad or
good and the gray area is too grey and
any
seceding of ground is you
allowing them to proliferate these
really terrible ideas
but sam harris has a great concept where
he talks about um
a the son of a terrorist over in iraq
and he says this
son is two years old so let's imagine
the free will that he's got he's two
years old
and he's maybe um stamping on insects or
something like that and you think well
is it his fault you go well no no like
look at look at the people he's around
he's got this aggression it's really
aggressive culture and blah blah blah
okay roll it forward he's seven years
old and he's at school and he's bullying
people
well is it his fault now well no no it's
still probably not his fault he's got
this crazy honor culture
and he's very very highly held within
society okay now
continue to roll the tape forward now
he's 15.
now he's 20. now he's a warlord at 30.
like
where where do we stop
or where do we draw the line about
understanding people's backgrounds
yeah no that's a really really good
point and a really good way of laying
out too
um at what point do we hold people
accountable for the things they believe
and can we allow them to change if they
want to and it seems like the far left
at this point before they can vote
like you know i mean if you're not
allowed to vote you basically
what we're saying to you what the
government is saying to you is your
views are not sufficiently well formed
for you to be able to contribute to the
national discourse
yeah they are so and how how can
anything from
circa that period be used as a
canary in a coal mine for what you're
like as a a real person a perfect
example
i don't think he can we've got a guy who
works for us a canadian dude called iffy
and
i was talking to him the other day and i
said i've just seen that you've changed
you've changed your twitter handle
why have you done that and he says man
like i've had twitter since i was like
11
and some of the [ __ ] that's on there
because he's doing law at the moment
he's i just don't want
in 10 years time someone to go back and
find the [ __ ] i was tweeting when i was
12 years old
yeah he's not got dreams of going into
[ __ ] congress but this is how
pervasive the situation is that people
are terrified of having something
dredged up
it's unbelievable this is why i call it
a panopticon because it really is
someone having the ability to see
everything about your life
if they just care to look you know um i
mean i
i tell you what i am so god damn glad
that social media didn't exist when i
was a child i am just
and i i'm gonna keep my son off of it
for as long as i can
because i mean it's awful it's awful the
idea that
like because i think that this is
something that's really thought about
but like
i think that people's pasts are
generally considered
to be in in regular society sort of a
part of their private lives
you know if something bad happened to
you in the past or you did something
silly
if you've paid the penance for it say
you went to jail or something
uh and you know like three years later
you're going for a job you know
it's appropriate to leave that in the
past because otherwise the person can
never improve
and they're never given any incentive to
improve and so i currently
effectively stuck being a criminal
forever um
and but now the way the internet works
is that no any link
can be sent to you and is as fresh as
the day it was
first printed you know first uploaded or
whatever and so
it's it's it's all there and it's gonna
be there forever
and so we're going to have to be really
really careful about what we say in
public i guess
it's a very nasty trail of breadcrumbs
back to a person that you never
or that you you no longer are i suppose
so am i right in thinking that sam
harris has closed his
patreon account now he has yeah so
dave so how many how many patrons do you
think are combined between them
i wouldn't even know it must be a fair
number though
50 000 probably maybe something like
that i i honestly don't know it's got to
be a lot though it's gotta be a lot
and they are now moving across to
uh they they're actually setting up
their own platform
but i don't know what it's called yet
okay um
but i'm i'm obviously going to be
looking forward to using it but i'm also
using subscribe star which is another
platform that was existing
before any of this happened you know so
i think it opened in may last year
and um and speaking to the cartel nature
of silicon valley in fact
um the the woman who was overseeing the
de-platforming of my patreon accounts
had worked at paypal for eight years and
uh and then she was put in charge of
patreon's trust and safety team
and then the day or the the day after um
i and a bunch of other youtube content
creators went to subscribe star which is
there are already content creators on
there yeah obviously um
and they've been operating quite happily
for about six months
um but we went over there and suddenly
paypal and all of the other
sort of um silicon valley processing uh
firms
decided to pull their services from
paper from from subscribe star
as if subscribe star had done something
wrong or as if we were being censored by
silicon valley itself
or something like that this is why i i
really am certain that it's a cartel
it's so juvenile isn't it
it's terrible yeah i mean if patreon
don't want me on okay
but what's that got to do with subscribe
to i mean like i still have a paypal
account
you know yeah still buying [ __ ] on ebay
and yeah
i haven't been the platform from paypal
so why when i or
a bunch of us go to another platform do
paypal pull out of that platform
it's like [ __ ] you still give me money
you know you're like
you do that so why are you so i can only
see it as being them protecting
the patreon from the competition because
obviously subscribe star is not based in
silicon valley
yeah so so has that been reversed now
what do you mean sorry the uh paypal not
accepting payments through no i i
believe subscribe star have figured out
a way to get around it by using some
other processor
probably outside of the us isn't that
bizarre that
bringing across some of the biggest uh
patreon or the biggest sort of
crowdfunded
uh content creators on the internet was
actually one of the worst things
probably operationally for about 24
hours that could have happened
well yeah i mean the thing is i don't
think anyone really expected paypal to
say right we're not going to do business
with you anymore
because none of the people who patreon
had done business with
had been a problem you know i mean we'd
all you know we'd all been on patreon
for years and patreon had no problem and
suddenly they're like oh that's not
politically correct enough we get we've
got an excuse to get rid of you
and we're not going to let you go to
another platform because we're going to
get paypal to
it's very very strange crazy crazy
juvenile so i want to move on to
the most current topic in the world at
hand which is the
this new gillette advert which i'm going
to guess that you will have seen
yes have you seen the british version of
it
no i haven't oh man i will make sure for
those yes
for those for those who are watching and
i will send it across to you but it's
the same
but the this is the funniest thing about
the whole everything to do with this
advert
that the british version is narrated by
scottish guy you're like the scottish
the scottish are the most
alpha males like i don't know man
scotland seems cooked to me
does it oh unbelievably so scotland is
unbelievably progressive
it's really bad like i and i i
i like the idea of the scots being a
bunch of rowdy
rowdy northern lads you know i like the
idea of them you know being
being scottish that's how that's the how
i kind of constructed
like exactly the same you did but like
man they they
for example the scottish government was
putting out a bunch of
uh on bus stop adverts just saying dear
transphobes we are afraid of your
transphobia
dear racists we hate your racism stuff
like this and it's like yeah so
i mean this is this goes back to what i
mean about the ethical state you know
the state has a goal above just being
the protector of your rights and
freedoms now they're like look you're
not
anti-racist enough you're transphobic
you need to change
and i don't think it should be up to the
government to try and decide your
opinions for you
i just don't i think that's just a moral
wrong and
you're giving the state an ethical
dimension that effectively puts you in
the same camp as mussolini
so you should probably stop that
scottish government because it's kind of
scary
you know it's not for you to decide
what's right and wrong you [ __ ]
lunatics
yep good point so for the viewers who
haven't seen
this gillette advert can you give me the
sargon of akkad cliff notes on what you
think it is or
how you would how would you describe it
someone that hasn't seen it it's just
feminist propaganda
it's it's just 101 and it's so it's so
basic i mean it starts off with the mean
two movements and toxic masculinity
so you know you're dealing with a
feminist i mean the the author the
the director sorry was um kim kim guerra
yeah she's a
famous feminist director she's who's
directed many controversial
um sort of short clips like this uh that
have
caused a stir because she seems to take
a one-sided feminist narrative
on the idea that women are being
oppressed by men and men have to change
yeah and i mean the way she was like the
whole thing conflates
like boys roughhousing as children with
harvey weinstein's predatory behavior in
hollywood
and then they have like terry crew who
again was
assaulted by a hollywood executive you
know some powerful hollywood exec
and it's all tied back as if it was
because harvey weinstein play fort with
his brother when he was a kid it's like
that's not the reason
you know the reason is because he's a
disgusting ugly repulsive pervert
with absolutely no moral standards he
doesn't represent anyone
but harvey weinstein and the goons
around him that he protects
you know that's not reflective of most
men and it's definitely inappropriate to
say that it is
yeah it's catastrophic thinking it's
absolutely worse isn't it
it's all it's bigoted thinking at its
absolute worst i mean
you know we we don't just sit there and
go black people look at these crime
rates you're all responsible
you know that would be ridiculously
racist so when they go men look at what
harvey weinstein's done you're
responsible
it's the same logic so yeah i don't know
so
during the advert the bit that really
really got me was this
i think they're a barbecue so there's a
bunch of guys at a barbecue doing man
things drinking beer and flipping
beef and stuff like that and there's a
couple of kids play fighting two boys
play fighting
and the scene is allowed to continue
then it cuts away and then it comes back
and the suggestion is that men should
step in
to stop other men or stop other males
i.e
boys from play fighting and you're right
that
the implication is that by allowing
boys to play fight you are fostering
this tyrannical
misogynist in waiting but it sounds
ridiculous when you say it
to anyone who either was a young boy or
who knows young boys you know who has
children or something like that it just
sounds absurd you know because young
boys play fighting is essentially
i looked up a bunch i went and
researched this to to do the
video i did on it um basically young
boys play fighting is completely normal
according to like leading psychologists
oh yeah and and i mean you know every
every man knows this because when they
were a kid
they had play fights with their friends
too you know it's it's just
like the way men socialize among
themselves and establish hierarchies
you know and like the one of the one of
the studies that i was
looking at um was uh 85
of of boys teenage boys could tell when
a play fight was going on you know like
85
of the time um they could tell the fight
was going there was a play fight because
you know they're having fun but and then
this was mostly like 70
adults as well like men and women who
had grown up with a brother
but women who'd grown up without a
brother always thought that the fights
were serious
and so it's like right okay there really
is a distinction here about male
female thinking you know and women who
are not used to what
young men are like don't recognize the
behavior for what it is
but the thing is it's the same with like
animals you know you see you know
puppies fighting and stuff like this you
know it's just [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah it's it's it's just
natural you know and so there
and they they panic about this
excessively
and so the kind of it it kind of is a
small group of mostly women who don't
really understand men and are kind of
afraid of them that's how i view
modern feminism these days that's
honestly how i view it because it's the
backlash the backlash on this gillette
advert has been insane
the um the youtube uh upright and down
rate was ten to one
on dislike and then yeah it was ten to
one
and then there was the views didn't
increase by a tremendous amount
i was watching this on a on youtube
yesterday
these didn't increase by a tremendous
amount and the
dislike to like has been brought back
down to around about five to one
oh really it was it was two to one when
i saw it the other day well in
it may have even gone further but when
it very very first went out and that may
be
due to just the first adopters of the
people who have taken the most offense
so you know it could be that could be
realistic
but there's a lot of accusations of a
bit of unfair play going around
i i've heard i've seen many people
saying my dislike has been removed and
things like this
comments a lot of comments are being
deleted and and
pinned ones are changing have you also
seen i don't know
i don't know how much truth's behind
this but it's on a there's a lot of
websites that are reporting it
have you seen that kim gerig has
actually been accused of sexual abuse by
two men and five women
no i did not know that the irony
i mean i guess we've got to listen and
believe haven't we yeah
i mean leave the victims yeah well yeah
definitely so i i
i'm struggling to find it on anyone who
is super reputable yet
i think it's probably dangerous to um
where i i will wait for confirmation
yeah exactly yeah gillette misandrist
where is it just gillette misunderstand
was directed by an accused pedophile
miss kim garrig one of her victims
committed suicide
oh my days well i mean we'll wait we'll
wait and find out a little bit more
about that but
yeah no matter what whether that's the
truth or not and even if it's not the
truth it probably speaks to
just how bipartisan it makes everything
do you know what i mean like
it's like okay well even if someone's
made that up they're like right
this is how far the feminist narrative
has tried to push
masculinity we need to we need to
come back with something that's even
more outlandish and ridiculous and
yeah this extremist sort of it's
it is it is just an entirely one-sided
argument
that they're having and the thing is the
only people on the
like like no no one no one in reality
thinks that boy
boys play fighting is a particularly
harmful behavior
because it's always by consent you know
i mean you know we're not talking about
bullying
obviously um bullying is something
different but like
the the pathologizing of just male
behaviors
and then i mean in the advert you know
when the dad goes up and says we don't
treat each other that way
it's like well they both consent you
know i mean you could see in the
in the clip they're showing you the two
boys have big grins on their face
yeah you know they couldn't have
portrayed it more as boys play fighting
yeah
it's better if they're trying exactly
you know and so
it's not wrong for them to treat each
other that way because they both consent
to being treated that way
you know they both consent to the sort
of competition of the rough and tumble
which is fine i mean you know it was fun
when i was a kid to
play fight with my friends i used to
like it you're totally right as well
it helps i'm sure if we had jordan
peterson at hand i'm sure he'd be able
to tell us exactly why but
exactly yeah i mean i'm waiting for the
commentary from him i imagine will be a
thesis on just how wrong gillette is in
terms of
upbringing of young men he'll give us
all the psychological literature as well
and the thing is although i can't cite
it and it's not my field
i've heard him across the content i've
consumed of him
talking about just how important this is
and how it
helps young boys to be able to learn the
limits of their own strength
and you the appropriate reception in
terms of
how your body moves and how other
people's bodies move and it's the games
iterated across time analogy he uses
talking about rats
and he says if one rat play fights with
another rat and then it loses it
rolls over and then the rat allows it to
come back and play again
yeah so yeah and you've got to let them
win 30 of the time roughly
exactly to keep them engaged in the game
yeah yeah yeah
i watch a lot jordan peterson too oh
there we go yeah no but i i think
i think that there's some definite
definitely some truth to it and i think
it's very much about socializing boys
because i think that
young men are very powerful this is what
this is what i think
i don't say women but a certain kind of
excessively concerned sort of moral
busybody
woman is usually like and i can i can
think of many
examples of this kind of they're not
badly intent intentioned or anything
um but i just don't think they
understand and i think that young men
men are strong they're a powerful force
in the world when they want to be
and this is usually why society's had
quite strict
rules for young men you know i mean like
if you go back to the middle ages you
know
young men would have been taught how to
use a spear and a shield and a bow and
things like this and they would have to
you know join you know become part of
the local sort of militia or something
like that or
gonna fight for the conscription of some
sort yeah there may well have been some
kind of
conscription exactly and and it it's
because it's understood that young men
have fighting instincts you know not all
of them all the time
but there is definitely a part to young
men that is naturally designed to fight
and i mean i watched their documentary i
think it was michael portello
a few years ago where he effectively
went and
like some kind of underground gang in
london it's like boxing gang yeah bare
knuckle boxing gang okay
and it was about the pleasure of
fighting because these these men who did
this
they they didn't take drugs or drink
their drug was
fighting itself the adrenaline kick of
it and
i think that like that's what call of
duty is tapping into
you know that kind of video game it's
that kind of adrenaline high
from conflict and combat catharsis
almost
no no no no no not quite that like not
the
like i like the
the the fact that physical competition
is also a game
you know it might become like a deadly
you know game in in
but it is there there are set rules and
the effect i mean in a war they're the
rules of who can kill who first you know
they don't have to be rules are
conceptual they might just be physical
rules
but there are set rules and there's an
objective and both of you are going for
it and it's understood that you're on
the same terms like
the for the reason it's not murder for
to kill a soldier in a battle you know
it's understood that you're both there
to fight and i think i think there's a
part of the male psyche that
is enjoys that you know and i for some
men i mean obviously you get
the sort of weaker men who don't like
these kind of physical competitions
and i think it's that kind of and it i
guess you call it primal if you want
um but that kind of urge that the you
know the shooter genre is tapping into
with kids these days you know
and i think it's wrong to try and deny
that aspect of of
human nature but obviously the feminists
who've got absolutely no empathy for men
whatsoever
and don't even try couldn't possibly
understand it and so all they see is oh
there is a defective woman as christine
hoff summers puts it
and i think she's right on that i think
they do yeah i think what's interesting
is the fact that
the scalable and much more effective
strategy
for controlling men or i.e making men's
behavior
more holistic and more beneficial to
society as a whole would be to
remodel it and have have it almost
brought on by desire as opposed to uh
entrenched and locked in by rules
so if you were if you were able to have
it be desirable for
all men to call out every man that was a
rapist immediately
or if you had it as a a rule that play
fights were
something that was taken pride in but
was done with a
with honor and with a sense of decorum
etc etc
that's much more scalable and it's much
more difficult because it's enforced by
the group
as opposed to choosing
a top-down approach that's a bottom-up
approach right which is manifested
naturally by the culture as opposed to a
top-down approach
which is this it's almost like trying to
litigate
here are the rules a group of people who
don't really understand you are going to
dictate rules for you
and now you're going to feel these rules
are chafing you know and
like so that there was a
a new zealand tv series called um
seven periods with mr gormsby and it was
about this old victorian
like yeah like like an old british
empire army officer
had moved to new zealand to teach a
group of kids who were often like you
know
maori and but not just maori you know
just a group of but it was a group of
boys
and i don't know why this thing
resonated with me but there was
something about it i found
unbelievably charming and it was because
of the old-fashioned way that gormsby
the teacher
treated the boys you know he he didn't
treat them
in the way the boys treated now as
they're not he didn't scold them
for acting like boys you know there's
fictional says you know it's
it's all a representation but i think
there's some there's some truth to what
like the idea of this because like fruit
and i
the way he was the way he would tell
them off is something that really
resonated with me it wasn't
you should not do that it was that's
enough
you know and so it's you know so when
the boys are fighting or playing around
being rambunctious whatever
it wasn't you know pathologizing them
and saying well you're wrong you you're
not you're doing this because you don't
even realize why and you shouldn't do it
because bad under every circumstance
it was just know the limit you know and
so you know don't it's not innately
wrong to be what you are
but it is wrong to go too far in what
you're doing and that's
i think the best way to try and um talk
to young men about
how to behave frankly if feminists want
to do that and they do want to do that
it's like okay well then as someone who
was a young man has
you know a son and a young man has a son
and
might have a bit more quote unquote
lived experience than your average
feminist in this regard
don't don't tell men they can't do
something just make sure that they
are doing it to within a restrict an
acceptable parameter
you know because then it's not bad for
them to be innately what they are yeah
speaking of chafing there is a scene in
the video where a man is shaving his
legs as well i think isn't it
have you seen that i i i can't remember
there is there's
yeah he's got it up on the couch i think
and he's shaving his legs which is
totally fine i've got
i've got some i've got some friends that
are swimmers that might you know what it
is that might actually only be in the uk
version
and if it is that's hilarious yeah i
don't recall that being in the u.s
definitely definitely exists um so i
don't have to watch that imagine
imagine for a second that i have made
you the
director of the exact opposite
advert so it's women it's women
telling women what women should do from
from a completely opposing narrative can
you can you try and run us through the
storyboard of what you think would
happen
well surely what i would want to happen
or what i think we'd end up with
know what you would what the equivalent
would be if they were to take the exact
polar opposite of what we've got
well it'd have to be something about
false rape allegations wouldn't it
so women false rape allegations begin in
the school
you know where so we'd we'd have
cavanaugh's trial
where he's being accused falsely by
three people who like recounted their
statements and one person
who just had absolutely no evidence or
no corroborating witnesses or even the
time of dates
when this is when the the accusations
are supposed to have happened
it seems there was nothing against
kavanaugh and he had unbelievably
reputable um female character witnesses
on his side
to back him up um so it would start with
something like that the the
the the stress of having to go through
this as kavanaugh
and then we'd we'd talk that back so you
know it's it's my young girl
i don't know i would i'd be
pathologizing some kind of
young woman's behavior where she's
getting playing with goals and
yeah yeah playing with dolls or getting
you know like you know
smiling at two different boys or
something yeah yeah i don't know you
know
it'd be some something about a natural
female behavior that you know that um
that
i would be trying to i would be trying
to make something that they need to stop
you shouldn't be putting your makeup on
during the morning you should be letting
your leg hair grow
well well yeah whatever it is but the
thing is i don't
think that the reverse should be made
obviously no you know
i obviously it's to illustrate just how
yeah
insane it is and i you know if you were
to tell
young girls that they should be less
feminine
yeah be awful why
i don't know yeah why would anyone do
that you know what a horrible thing to
do
like stop playing with dogs like what
you are yeah
no you're not allowed you're not allowed
to have your own choice i don't know i
it's it's a it really is an interesting
one so the uh
the i guess that this speaks volumes to
just how pop culturally we are at the
moment
but the fact that brexit sits below the
gillette advert on my list of things i
wanted to talk about today
but um can you give us the uh
carl benjamin rundown of what's happened
over the last week
um okay well the the theresa may is a
massively unpopular prime minister but
the conservatives are terribly afraid
about losing
their control over the government and so
they have to back her but what she's
what theresa may is proposing is so uh
outside of the bounds of reason to the
hardline euro skeptics of the tory party
that her position is tremendously weak
um but she does keep managing to survive
votes with no confidence apparently
unbelievably so yeah i but it's only
because the tories know that if she
goes they all go because they've pinned
their colors to her mask it's like well
that was a mistake wasn't it
you know it's it's really bad and
they're convinced that they have to have
a deal and
i mean you can you know the the head of
the world trade organization said well
yeah okay if you
if you leave on world trade organization
terms there will be a
a small period of disruption but it
won't be the end of the world
and then we'll be able to carry on as an
independent country i would rather take
the small period of disruption
even if it means i have to pay more for
this or you know a flight of mine is
delayed or something like that you know
i'll
accept it for the sovereignty of my
country and we'll figure it out
you know that's the thing i have faith
in the british people to figure these
things out and our political class just
has
absolutely no faith in this regard
they're they're concerned about like
yeah but what about gdp it's like man i
don't really care
you know i i care that we get out of the
european union i don't want them
controlling us
i don't want to be under the
jurisdiction of their courts i don't
want their foreign policy to be our
foreign policy i just want us to have
left
you know no more laws no more
interference just nothing
and i'm prepared i'm prepared to watch
gdp shrink a bit for that i'm sorry
it's i this is a point of principle in
my position and
in my opinion now and the conservatives
don't think that that can be done they
think that
they think that they can push through a
deal that the european union will agree
to but the deal is awful as i mean
you know you can watch any of the
euroskeptics just excoriate it all the
time
as being effectively a a submission to
brussels
because it is i mean it puts all of the
power in their hands and we have
absolutely none
and it would if it would be better to
remain than take that deal but we have
voted to leave
so we must leave so we have to go on no
deal because the european union have
said they're not going to renegotiate
at all because they're being utterly
intransigent about this in order to try
and punish
the conservatives presumably in the rest
of the country rightly
rightly so on their side like if you've
understandable you've made your [ __ ]
bed
yeah and i understand them but the thing
is i think that it's going to come back
and bite them in the ass because i think
that what they expected is they could
beat teresa down into into proposing
almost anything and they did and she has
but she can't get that through
parliament so they're not going to get
the deal they want
and there are going to be consequences
to britain leaving on a wto brexit
and these consequences will be bad there
will be some negative consequences
for us but there are definitely going to
be negative consequences for them for
example um
was the german finance minister the
other day was raising the
alarm about the fact that if we didn't
pay our 39 billion
that's french german italian and dutch
taxes that go up
uh how do you think the french are going
to take that probably
probably not brilliantly considering
they're still writing i'm sure the
germans aren't going to be thrilled
i doubt the i doubt salvini i'll even
open the open the email
yeah salvia you're going to raise the
taxes yeah bollocks do i whatever you
know
yeah and then the next the the
netherlands exit movement will grow
incrementally stronger so do you think
that's coming as well
no not not in the not in the short term
but um i think it'll fester
like the same with brexit in fact i
think it'll fester for a number of years
until people demand a referendum
you know um assuming that you even last
that long and then you've got the
problem with ireland right
so the the irish economy is deeply tied
to the british economy especially the
food economy
and we're talking like hundreds of
millions of tons of beef and cheese
every year
and if we don't carry on trading with
the eu
in the way that we did before if the eu
says we're not gonna we're not gonna you
know we're gonna put tariffs on you et
cetera et cetera
then they're worried that we're gonna
start getting beef and cheese from south
america
which will actually make our beef and
cheese cheaper that it was and it will
destroy ireland's economy because the
money that they would have taken from us
is actually now going to go to argentina
and brazil and places like that it's
like well
there we go it is an interconnected
house of cards isn't it
yeah i mean one of the one of the things
about this the ireland is
it's already said that it's going to
have to start requesting more money from
the european union
in the event of any brexit which is
going to turn ireland from a net
contributor into
a net beneficiary of the european union
so the the eu
again loses it's it's lose you know it's
immediately losing two of its net
contributors
britain being the second biggest one and
ireland being a net contributor but
obviously not a very big one
um but that's that's all bad news for
the french and german taxpayer really
so can you think can you
can you think about what it's like to
wake up as theresa may
every morning for the last week i'd
rather not
okay yeah well yeah given she's done
this to herself though
it's right this is the most annoying
thing that theresa may i find is that
it's completely within her power to go
you know what
everyone's wrong i'm gonna make a
decision and it's it's just gonna be
this way like
i we're going to go with no deal she can
you know just say no deal we're going to
start
and we can unilaterally do all of the
things that we would offer the european
union
so we can say look we're not going to do
anything bad to you know obviously we're
going to give
european citizens like you know rights
of rights to stay right to work et
cetera we'll give them citizenship hell
with it i don't care you know
um we won't impose a border along the
irish
along northern ireland irish border
we're not going to put any tariffs on
your trade we're going to carry on as
normal
and then the ball's in your court you
know what are you gonna do
and then she's the one who's calling the
shots
yeah yeah she doesn't do because she's
weak you know yeah
i mean the fact that the fact that you
have a a parliament a party behind her
which doesn't support her
but which also doesn't have also doesn't
have the balls
to be able to get rid of her is such
a it's the most british situation
do you not think yeah i do yeah yeah
yeah it's so quintessentially british
it really is uh you know like
like okay one of the things i've i've
always got to remember about the remain
campaigners
is they're not cowards they're just
wrong
you know they'll go out there and they
will march you know
they'll go out there in large numbers
for their cause and they'll stand there
like you know
i interviewed a few the other day
outside of parliament standing there in
the cold and the rain and
you know they're standing there waving
they they truly believe in what they're
saying
you know it's not that they're it's it's
not that you know that they're
they're weak people individually or
necessarily
it's that they are just confused in my
opinion
but the parliament it really is kind of
like a you know parliament of lambs
leading a country of lions you know
because at this point like i think a lot
of people even if they vote remain
they're just like look just get on with
it you know
you know we you know stiff upper lip we
can take it we'll just we'll just
go with him whatever it is let's just
have it happen exactly you know
but the the the parliament is a very
remain parliament and it's very weak
and they're always kind of you know like
rubbing their hands and like looking at
one another oh
you know passing the responsibility on
it's like just just
get on with it yeah totally i don't know
whether you saw when the actual
announcement happened i don't watch a
lot
of the discourse that occurs in
parliament
but i mean like to just see how archaic
and like old and worldy it is it's just
this is why everyone thinks that british
people
drink shitloads of tea and constantly
wear things that have got wood
on them and like they've all got bad
teeth like this is this is why and the
guys they're
bowing and then they walk forward and
then they bow again
and then this lady reads about the nose
to the left and the eyes to the right
and then they give it to the speaker and
he starts shouting about the nose and
the eyes and you're like
this is going out on the [ __ ] world
stage
guys
i kind of like that though i like it but
it's i like it because it is
embarrassing though i got it
yeah i i like it because it's got this
sense of heritage
which i appreciate in a more nuanced way
because i'm british and because it
reminds me of
you know 1945 and yorkshire tea and
[ __ ] like that but like
[ __ ] me imagine like just anyone anyone
imagine the italians
imagine the italians watching this like
are the americans watching this and
they're like i think i think that a
large number of them view it as
um distinguished really
yeah and the thing is it is in many ways
like
i i i have problems with john burko
and the things that he does but i have
actually no problem with the way he
rules parliament i think it's hilarious
i love his put downs it's like we will
get along without you if you can't
control yourself
yeah yeah it's yeah
it's you know it's such a unique and
culturally british thing that i
i would love to see it go away i think
it's i think it's adorable
you are right and it it is embarrassing
if you're british
because you're looking and thinking well
that doesn't really represent me
but the thing is like you know if it
went away that would be something that
looking from the outside i think it's
it's
like like when i'm looking at like you
know the chinese festivals where they're
you know cutting a dragon down the
street yeah you know me it's just this
wild wacky
thing i'm watching but it's entertaining
and i think that i imagine for
foreigners it's much the same
yeah you're probably probably right it's
the distillation of everything that
everyone accuses
britain of being i remember i got a when
i got my master's degree from newcastle
there was a mace bearer and everyone had
to doth their caps
yeah and this guy's walking in and i'm
like looking i'm looking at the
timetable on the thing i'm sat next to
my mum and dad and i'm like there's a
[ __ ] there's a guy with a mace here i
don't know what he's gonna do and sure
enough
next thing i know some guy walks in with
a medieval weapon
and robes that look like something out
of harry potter and then he dots his cap
and the the announcer dots his cap and
he just like
there's a a real old and worldly
cuteness about it
yeah but i just it really does concern
me about how that plays out on the
international stage you know i i say um
[ __ ] it that i say that you know let's
should we double down on it
yeah i think so yeah i i no no that's
exactly what that's exactly one thing is
just chad doubling down on it
yep just being like yeah no this is this
is exactly what we and and this is the
thing it's like your countries might be
like 10 minutes old
but ours is over a thousand years old
yeah we've got some [ __ ] baggage to
get over here
exactly these are these traditions that
we spent a long time building up
you know this ridiculous outfit and
procession
it didn't just happen overnight exactly
some credit
yeah you try and make that happen in
your country see how long it takes you
yeah thousand years i'll give you a
thousand years and you can come back
with a man with a mace
and everyone drinking tea and everyone
can have bad teeth yeah yeah yeah
man well it's it's amazing isn't it but
like it's so
it's i i do find it increasingly more
adorable
as as time goes on like you know i when
i was younger i used to find it terrible
oh god that's so awful and like you know
embarrassing you know
but then i mean you go to like i went to
rome
recently like see um the vatican city
and you see the guards in their
ridiculous outfits
yeah and they think wow the beef eaters
look cool by comparison
you know these guys look like like
jesters or something you know
but um and so yeah i'm i'm down with
keeping the traditions even if they look
gay
yeah it looks so they do look
incredibly odd but man carl i i've
absolutely loved today thank you very
much for your time i will make sure that
the link to
your youtube channel and everything else
that we've spoken about are in the show
notes below
and i am about to send you the advert of
a man a scottish man
talking about shaving your legs i can't
wait
thanks very much thanks buddy bye
you